yeah I'm very happy to be here
um I'm going to talk about the work that
I and my students have been doing for
about 10 years now I was
writing a review article and I realized
this could be a nice talk so I call this
anytime anywhere all at once and if you
haven't seen a movie which I'm obviously
inspired by
there are no spoilers here although you
should see the movie
that's a good one and uh my set my
subtitle here data analytics in the
metaverse of course a little provocative
this word means nothing nowadays or this
is an effort to reclaim the term uh to
and I'll try to explain how in the next
few slides but the basic premise of the
work that I do at least this slice I'll
talk about today is the observation that
in our today's society we're
increasingly collecting data everywhere
about what's going on not just online
but also in the uh real world you know
all the purchases are movements reviews
decisions we make products we buy so on
is is being tracked and if we take all
the privacy and security problems with
this and there are many and put them
aside we can think of the possibilities
of using this data for for decision
making and personal uh uses as well as
for professional uses maybe for
companies and similar so increasingly
we're also seeing that this data
is being used and analyzed anywhere
because of course we're all accustomed
to having smartphones in our pockets
and we have all kinds of apps and
services available to us the question is
what would data analysis look like when
it can be accessed anywhere
so the overall idea of this everywhere
and anywhere data that's the starting
point for my NSF career in 2013 it's
been almost 10 years
but it's this observation that that we
have data from everywhere we can access
it anywhere we can think of data
analysis utility the question is what
kind of opportunities
would be available if we can start
putting this data to good use
now a little bit about myself you heard
the intro I am originally Swedish and
came to the US in 2008 I was a professor
at Purdue came to Maryland in 2014 and I
became the director of the hcil in 2016
and I was a director for five years
until it was a good way to step down
last year so I was the seventh director
the first was Ben Schneiderman who
founded the lab in 1983.
and since 2019 I'm a full professor and
the work I do in general is data
visualization
maybe I have short attention span or
maybe a better word for it as I'm a
generalist so I've worked across the
entire spectrum of data visualization
work
the kind of applications of course that
I'm concerning myself with today are
first of all these mobile field settings
if you are on your own Solo in a on the
go and you have your mobile phone
available what kind of data analysis
would you be able to do at the moment
these kinds of
device applications are not very common
data the data visualization field hasn't
really looked so much at them
when you move into a group setting in
the field
you might have more than one device
available multiple people but in this
case you'll see these two young women
the devices are not really helping them
they're trying to look at each other's
screens
here's the challenge how do we make
these kinds of situations more practical
maybe you find a place to put down your
computer you are more static setting
you're no longer on the go coffee shop
or your office maybe a conference room
but here the challenge is
you probably have more than one device
at your disposal but current devices are
designed for solo use not really for
multiple devices at the same time so the
fact that you have a smartphone and a
laptop and a tablet it's not going to
help you so so how do we look at
situations where we can have these
devices stack and multiply
and this all becomes even more
challenging in group settings conference
room people show up with their laptops
just getting sharing information or
making effective use of all this display
space is challenging
so even if we have multiple devices they
don't really multiply They Don't Really
stack at least not for data analysis
sessions
so put these four settings together you
get the playing field for what I call
ubiquitous analytics which is
essentially a blending of ubiquitous
Computing and multiple devices from that
realm and data visualization and visual
Analytics now of course if these
discussions sound familiar it's because
they are this is uh Mark Weiser he's the
head of the computer science department
at Xerox Park just about three miles
from here I I looked up before I came
here which is really cool and in 1991 he
wrote a famous paper called a computer
for the 21st century and the quote you
see here
is the very first line of that paper
most profound Technologies are those
that disappear they weave themselves
into the fabric of everyday life until
they are indistinguishable from it
and of course you can make a case that
today's
environment with mobile phones
smartphones and every person's pocket
more than I think six or eight billion
of these devices in existence today most
of them now available able to access the
internet
means that ubiquitous Computing is here
it has come we don't just recognize it
it looks slightly different from the
vision that Mark Weiser who's hailed as
one of the fathers of ubiquitous
computing
thought of you know he talked about
disposable tabs computers tablets you
could use and then throw aside so they
were not personal
uh I talked about making devices in your
surrounding area speak to you or Pro
divide information so we have a similar
situation it just looks a little
different
and this argument was discussed a couple
of of years ago in an article on saying
uh Chris Harrison another saying that
what we have today is more of a quality
Computing situation we have one device
one personal device maybe a tablet too
instead of lots of disposable devices
but we still have this situation and the
question is what does this look like
when we apply a data visualization to
work so that's the starting point for
the work that I began around 2010 and
then we'll had an NSF career in 2013. so
I call this ubiquitous analytics and I
thought of this as the use of multiple
networked digital devices
to enable a metaverse for data analytics
and this word here again it's a
convenient shorthand
for thinking of these
day a data world the parallel world to
our own that we can Pierce use multiple
devices as portholes or even immersive
devices to see so that we can analyze in
data anytime and anywhere
now what would you want to do this of
course the technology is there but
we also want to I also want to point out
that there are good reasons from Human
cognition that says that Distributing
our sense making of data into our
environment is a good idea
so so-called post-cognitive Frameworks
that have been around for about 20 30
years
and and cognitive psychology
so these are things like distributed
socially distributed computing uh
cognition I mean extended cognition and
bodied cognition
they say that cognition human cognition
is the system it's not just what's
inside our skulls in our brains but it
also involves other people
physical artifacts
history
etiquette culture all of these things
contribute to helping us think
so to to bring this point home just
imagine things like
Post-it notes or your calendar on your
phone these are extensions of your
memory
we have physical
environment and the way we organize our
physical space to help computation so
just imagine cooking food and arranging
all the ingredients that you still
haven't put into your dish on the left
side of the dish and then the ones that
you have on the right side that we
commonly use physical space to Aid
cognition
and also just the fact that if you have
a group of multiple people
they provide multiple viewpoints they
provide multiple expertise and role roll
different roles in your collaboration
so that's another way to think of
cognition you know even if people in a
group they're not neurons they're not
synops as in the brain they are still
components of a cognitive system formed
by the people that contribute and
collaborate
so the whole premise of of my work here
is to say if we're going to distribute
Computing we can better scaffold and
support sense making by making the
devices that we already use
active and part of the sense making
process
and of course as I mentioned already
the as technology progresses we start to
see augmented in mixed reality devices
and displays that enable us to put
um
you know computer Graphics or content on
the world itself to further support this
kind of setting
all right so I'm going to use this bagel
and if you've seen the movie you might
remember the bagel this will be my
organizing principle
for this talk I'll talk about platforms
I'll talk about some of the media that
becomes available for this kind of
ubiquitous analytics environment
I'll mention collaboration and some
examples there because the moment we
start putting sense making in the world
we open the doors for multiple people to
contribute and then I'll go through a
couple of applications at the end of
this thing so that's my roadmap
for today so let's start with platforms
and if some of these images you see in
the background then you'll note I'm a
recent mid-journey con convert so I
went overboard with some of these
um this picture here is not from the
journey this is my lab from 2010 at
Purdue
and it showcases some of the kind of
display display environments that I'm
talking about where on the wall we have
a tile display and then a tabletop
horizontal touch display in the center
and uh and the far right corner you
might see someone's hand holding a
tablet so
the key thing we I was going after in
building this lab was just to recognize
that in a in a future Computing
environment it's going to consist of
multiple devices they are different
computers it's not just a single beefy
computer running them all because if you
do that's almost like cheating you know
if you use put in graphical car graphics
cards in one computer and then plug up a
bunch of monitors then a lot of this
management of display space and shared
resources and Computing become trivial
so we wanted
in particular to to think about multiple
devices that all collaborate
and this first work called polychrome
might be I think it's the third second
or third generation of platforms that we
built to enable stitching together all
of these devices and providing a common
uh canvas for creating these these
visualizations and in this particular
case the system called polychrome was
built using web Technologies and just
recognizing that the web browser today
it runs on almost all devices from smart
watches all the way to Smart TVs
they have some form of modern web
browser and of course web browsers today
are very full function featured I mean
they they have Hardware acceleration
they have font rendering Vector
rendering they handle sound full motion
video and so on so there's it's it's a
great starting point for building
essentially a distributed operating
system where each node is just a browser
and on top of that we build
uh build software just using JavaScript
the polychrome system that I'm showing
here was an entirely peer-to-peer based
system
so there was no server instead it was
just broadcasting within the same lab
that I just showed you so it it just
enables you in this case to replicate a
Dom a document object model for a single
website or the web page across multiple
devices and you make changes to one it
will be for reflected in the others
so this video I can show you some some
excerpts it's nothing special about it
but it's just showcasing a simple D3
visualization
where we're just replicating the Dom so
when you make changes to one of them
another computer will see instantaneous
updates so all the events on one uh gets
sent to the other so again nothing
spectacular but the thing this enables
us to do is we can start building
distributed applications with different
displays that we can stitch together
so the fourth generation most current
generations of this work is called
vistrates it's a collaboration with some
colleagues at orhers University in
Denmark
and we in this iteration stepped away
from the peer-to-peer server
architecture peer-to-peer architecture I
should say into a more traditional
client server architecture just
recognizing that peer-to-peer is super
elegant but it gets into lots of
consistency concerns especially as
you're broadcasting and collaborating
across long distances you get a lot of
issues in broadcasting so we ended up
using Appliance server and approach in
this case it's a again it's a replicated
Dom
that runs on a server we use operational
transform same technology that Google
came up with for Google wave and now
using Google docs to to make sure that
any changes made to the the Dom gets
replicated in the correct order to avoid
inconsistencies
and along the way you get a lot of nice
features like versioning and and uh and
so on so
it it lets you build shareable Dynamic
visualizations very simply and the this
traits system as it's called also
provides a component-based framework
built entirely in JavaScript but it
enables you to to bring together the
entire ecosystem of web libraries like
leaflet for maps
D3 or Vega for visualizations plotly or
high charts a lot of these things can
just be brought together very
effortlessly and even built
using with no programming so let me show
you this video it's going to go a little
fast here and I apologize I don't have
time to go into detail but what you're
seeing is a computational notebook it's
a computational littered programming
interface to this rates and what we're
doing is we're bringing in a bunch of
standard components one for a map one
for a filter algorithm one for a bar
chart I think and then in this view here
we're switching to a canvas view we're
just invoking the visual representations
of all these components and on the right
side you'll see us connecting up so that
the data that was loaded gets sent into
the input ports of a bar chart and a map
and we're essentially wiring them
together without any programming so in
the end what we get is is uh interactive
dashboard
see if this finishes and you'll see how
this works where you can click on the
map and the map bar chart will update or
you can click on the bar chart and the
map will update
again the beauty here is that any of
these components on them on their own
could be placed on a smart Farm phone or
on a tablet or on a tile display and
everything would still be synced up and
work live
all right so the takeaway here from the
this first part on platforms
we found that in building these
Multi-Device environments cross-device
infrastructures
we needed to have a clear role for each
of the devices that's involved and we
want to make sure that transitions
between them are seamless
yes so the the complementary angle I buy
a lot now but I'm not sure I saw the
demos I I want to like push that a
little harder can you say a little bit
about like what are the kinds of
complementary modes that you ended up
producing that really worked like uh was
it that the the small devices the phones
were sort of you know lenses that were
focused on specific things and but like
there was the person at the control room
who was like what what are the modes and
what's the estimates here that really
resonates right so I have a few examples
I'll show you soon but um basically when
you have often it's some kind of
asymmetric situation so in the example
I'll show here is is a system where you
have a large display with potentially
multiple people in front of it it's
touch display but then if you want to do
something uh on an individual basis I
want to save a query I want to explore
data and have some some subset then I
would bring that to my personal
Smartwatch and I would do those those
complementary tasks on the Smartwatch or
the smartphone and if I'm happy with
them I can publish them back so I think
is that sort of what you're
yeah so in that case it's it and that is
not part of this particular presentation
its work actually will was part of
called Branch Explorer merge one in the
audience here one of my former students
where we essentially used revision
control methodology to to Branch away
from the tabletop do work on your own
personal device and then merge it back
into the tabletop if you found it
yeah absolutely
all right so that was the first piece of
the bagel so second here is on on the
media
so what kind of unique forms of media
are now available to us the first being
just the display infrastructure this
display space itself
so imagine that you have
a Multi-Device environment and it's this
kind of environment is probably going to
change dynamically as you go through
your day so as you walk from
the parking garage doing data analysis
on your mobile phone as you do
um you only just have a phone right when
you get to your office all of a sudden
you have your desktop computer
and the moment you have this new device
if there's if you have to spend time
housekeeping moving the views around
correctly that's the moment you're gonna
say okay I'm gonna stick to one device
and especially as you move let's say to
a conference room later later on in the
day and you have other people you have a
large projected display again if you
have to do the housekeeping to manage
more than one device you're probably not
going to do it so in this system called
this tribute our goal was to say could
we automatically handle the layout of
the views in a data visualization
dashboard
depending on the dynamic availability of
devices
and of course you don't want to do this
blindly because some visualizations
belong together for example if I have a
a bunch of stock market data and I'm
showing it as a timeline chart I
probably want to keep those together so
that they have a common Baseline so I
can compare across the same time for all
stocks
so what we did here is we came up with a
bunch of heuristics you see an example
of the lower left part of the slide here
of just how our views related maybe
because they are similar maybe because
they share data maybe because they have
explicit connections like you have a
node link diagram where where individual
entities are connected so you want to
use that as a heuristic going to the
constraint solving that is done
automatically as the available devices
change so the vistibute system here I'll
show you a demo first starting with a
single dashboard on a laptop and the
moment you bring in in this case a phone
you'll see one of the devices that the
bar chart popped onto the phone and then
in this case the the line chart the
stock market data in this particular
case came onto the um the tablet I'll
play that again so
the observation of course also is that
some device some visualizations just
want to be big like a map they want as
much space as possible some
visualizations they like to be wide and
thin or some other configuration so all
of these things can go into the
constraint solving in doing this layout
the other media I'll talk about here
there's a bunch of other forms of media
ranging from just multimodal uh
different representations and
interactions but I'll talk about this
one which is computation the other side
of the coin if you have multiple devices
each of them has computational power and
assume that you're in some kind of
situation perhaps you're running
computations on one device and it's
going slowly you could take advantage of
the fact that you have more devices in
your pocket to literally increase your
computational power
so this this High project it's again
entirely JavaScript based it doesn't use
an explicit server one of the nodes in
the system will become the server
and without any download it enables you
to share computation for something let's
say a cluster into these local clouds
so if you're doing some cluster
algorithm let's say and it's going
slowly you can just bring up a tablet
and the the load will be shared across
them so it's hard to show a really
engaging video of this but I'll show you
here just a brief sample of in this case
two two tat laptops and laptops and a
smartphone of course the smartphone is
not going to have a lot of computational
power to contribute it's just to show
you the idea
and in the end we could
show here at the end of some some it's a
DB scan cluster algorithm uh and in the
end it's going to result in
the cluster finishing
yeah oops
all right so the takeaway here is
overall it's about automation
because the moment as I said you have to
to to to to start doing a lot of
housekeeping a lot of these ideas will
go out the window so you have to
automate and minimize
a lot of these challenges yes
any significant amount of time for kind
of the visualization to switch over of
people starting to get frustrated with
that lab yeah so
we didn't explicitly look at lag but it
is definitely a big factor this work
from a couple of years ago that found if
if you have more than half a second of
latency people's engagement in the
visualization will suffer so you'll
start not paying attention it will not
become a conversation anymore you're
going to phase you know basically phase
out for a bit while you're waiting so I
I it is definitely a big concern that we
have to keep in mind
but we haven't studied it explicitly in
this work
all right so the third piece here
is on collaboration because as I said
the moment we put computation in the
world and not just on your desktop
computer in your office
you can have multiple people
collaborating
so
in one of these projects I'll talk about
from a couple of years ago we were
looking at the idea of proxemics and
proxamix has been suggested is an a way
to to
use how people relate to space as a way
to guide ubiquitous Computing and things
like that so proxamix is this branch of
Psychology from the 50s I think where
um
the way you as a person relate to
physical artifacts and other people
tells
tell something about what you are
thinking and what you're you're trying
to do
so in this particular work we had this
idea that if you have multiple people
again in front of a shared large display
sometimes these people will want to work
independently
and sometimes they'll want to work with
each other and we can determine this
implicitly by just observing what
they're doing
so um it's a you know that this is a
it's a tricky slope here because you
certainly don't want to get to trying to
understand what the person wants and go
all the way to the clippy Spectrum right
so you want to find some balance here
and this paper became an evaluation of
finding that balance which actions do
you want to do implicitly and which
actions needs to be done explicitly and
we found in general that there's a need
for both and if you're doing an action
that will have an explicit well a strong
impact on the visualization you will
want to do that explicitly this video
you'll see two people they all have a
lens and as they approach each other
the lenses overlay and then erase their
hand the lenses actually merge so that's
an explicit action now if they then
start on splitting them and then they
they leave they move away we is if we
inter well we think of that as as they
are no longer interested in in
collaborating directly or closely so
again we have the this these lenses
they're controlled by their gaze they
approach the proxemics tell us that
they're collaborating you know you
converse with someone you approach them
and then as they move apart that is
interpreted as as they want to they want
to loosen the coupling they're no longer
working closely together
this final one I mentioned already a
little bit about the complementary types
of devices
we call this David and Goliath it's a
study of large displays and smart
watches Goliath being the big thing and
the Smartwatch being the small one
and we found here that there are
needs especially if you have multiple
people for putting some personal
information on your personal device a
smartwatch is very personal it's even
hard for another person to see it you
know you have to really crank your arm
to to let someone else see it so it has
a very personal connotation
and we found that that there were
certain things like storage or even um
using it as a remote control would be
was useful for this this Smartwatch
device so this is Tom introducing
interacting with this large display and
you'll see him do some actions where
he's swiping towards his body it just
means whatever I was interacting with
I'm storing it on my device and then he
goes to another play part of the screen
and he swipes away from his body which
means I'm now placing whatever
I stored on my device onto the large
display the dashboard that you're seeing
so here we found just as in any
collaboration
things like consensus
and coordination are key aspects and the
benefit of having multiple devices is
that some many times you can make this
kind of coordination and collaboration
straight forward
all right so last piece here
on some of the applications that we have
explored and continue to explore for
ubiquitous Analytics
first one is a paper from Kaya this year
just this past spring where it's called
relive we worked with colleagues from
University of constance in Germany
and we had this problem where we're
trying to understand mixed reality
studies when people are moving around in
a physical space you know this is a
essentially a research tool that we were
using for our own research in other
projects so relive is all about
being able to view 3D tracked data in 3D
space
and we found in that situation that
there is a need both for doing in-situ
analysis where I'm stepping into the 3D
space and I'm I'm seeing these 3D traces
of how people moved around what they
were doing during a user study
and there was a need for more of an
ex-situ analysis when I'm sitting at my
desk
I have a high Precision mouse and a high
resolution monitor I can you know I see
a dashboard I can do analysis I have a
more abstract nature so we needed both
of these interfaces so what we ended up
doing was creating an interface you can
see that in the picture here that
enables you to switch between one and
the other so it's a form of a hybrid
user interface where sometimes you do
things in VR and sometimes you do them
outside in just a desktop and the key
thing we found also in order to make
this work we had to make sure that there
were explicit anchors
between the two interfaces so that when
you were in VR you still had some
you saw some reminders of what was what
you were doing on the desktop side and
vice versa
so this video here will show you the VR
view only but it shows the 3D traces the
yellow lines here that's how two
different people were moving their
tablets in 3D space and this is another
project that our colleagues and
Universal constants were doing
and they had found the needed an
analysis tool for this you'll see that
there's a a Time
slider here that we can manipulate to
move these tablets in 3D space as time
progresses during the study
and then we can also even bring up some
some of the user interface components
from that look very familiar from the
desktop version of this interface
so that you you can have that anchor
that connection between the desktop
interface and on the desktop side you
always had a 3D view of what you had
been seeing when you were in VR
the last thing I'll talk about is a
paper that is brutally destroyed by the
kai reviewers I'll talk about it anyway
it's uh one of my the coolest Works
we've done recently so hopefully no one
here killed it uh the paper is called
visualization
it is
an augmented reality authoring system
for creating visualizations using a
hotline lens really cool work in my very
biased opinion
uh probably we spent so much time on it
so so we're kind of devastated but
um
the the the system here as the name kind
of suggests bad pun
we had this observation that when you're
authoring visualizations in 3D using
augmented reality you're using a lot of
gestures and speech and it kind of felt
like magic right you were casting spells
so that's how we we leaned into this and
um used it as a metaphor for for the
system so what we're doing is we're
providing a system where you enter you
create entries using a grammar or
Graphics to build essentially
visualizations 3D visualizations
in midair so this I know it's a very
detailed image here but here's some
examples of of that grammar it's a basic
Json declarative specification for
uh for graphic representations so you
see at the bottom and then these are
produced using discrete gestures and
speech commands so the gestures are
drawn from American sign language
because we wanted something that was
more or less standardized so you can you
can do this
the video is is also it's four different
views I know it's a little a lot of
things going on here but what you're
seeing are three different people this
on the lower left is my student Andrea
in Maryland and then these are my
colleagues at Bangor University in the
UK in the same physical not physical
space same virtual space they are
they are casting spells well they're
because they're authoring visualizations
after a while you'll see them here but
one after another they're adding classes
to a declarative specification of a of a
visualization that is going to show up
eventually or it's a scatter plot and of
course they they can all see the same
thing be in the same space and interact
with each other
and oh yeah and one thing to add here
too is that this is all built using um
web-based just as the previous ones I
said I I feel strongly about web-based
Technologies for a lot of the
infrastructures that we built that's
true for this as well a lot of the
development that's done in data
visualization for VR and augmented
reality has been done in unity
and I I um I'm a little troubled by that
because the unity is a close platform
and propriety proprietary also
okay all right so let me just close with
this take away and I'll talk a little
bit about the other work that we're
doing in my group so first of all the
takeaway from these applications what we
found is if if we're going to see a
future
of creating
data visualizations in VR and AR we're
going to have to have to get some kind
of standardized systems where you can
have just like an in a graphical
operating system you can have multiple
applications running and they coexist so
we have to start thinking about
interoperability so we can have modular
and standardized interfaces
all right so this is the just an
overview of the things that I've talked
about right now in my research group
we're interested in a couple of
different themes Beyond this thing it's
a big obviously component in my research
a last few years has seen
people starting to discuss accessibility
aspects of database in particular blind
users using data visualization
I
in in Fallout 2019 I had a blind student
sign up for my data visualization class
which really uh made me reconsider my
view of data visualization so this is
currently a big Topic in my group
we're doing a bunch of aspects of using
human-centered AI techniques you know
that's partly why I'm excited to visit
Stanford with your Center here on using
you know putting putting AI techniques
into the hands of users and the picture
you see here represented on the upper
right you presented this at the this
conference about uh three weeks ago it
is a virtual eye tracker where we
trained using crowd-sourced
eye tracking data on data visualizations
we trained a CNN so that given a new
visualization you can feed it in and you
get an A saliency map saying
what would a person looking at this for
the first time focus on
which is useful information for the
signer you know I'm sitting down I'm
designing a new visualization
not having to run a full-fledged eye
tracking study which costs money and
time of course
to give some fine quick uh rough
feedback is very useful
I have a student that's very invested
and talented at building things so we're
exploring physical Computing aspects for
database
and then also another another theme is
just visualization recommendation and
data science recommendation in
computational notebooks
okay that's it for me I'm happy to take
questions thank you
foreign
regarding the visualization paper
um which that seems super interesting so
I'm sorry that one didn't work out like
that but um I'm curious what the what
the advantage was to having the gesture
recognition
um alongside the speech recognition
because my thought would be speech
recognition is probably a lot easier
um and a lot less sort of intensive and
and uh things like that so I'm curious
what what was the advantage in that case
of adding the the gestures
um did it enable more uh like commands
or was it sort of a
just a a different way for people to
interact with the visualizations like
so it is definitely a lot about the
being able to precisely point and select
when you have created a data
visualization during the authoring I
agree with you that you can be more
specific many times using
um
uh just a speech so that is heavily what
is used during the although you can do
both but but most people prefer speech
when they're building a data
visualization but once you are let's say
you make a mistake you can use your
gestures to select which clause that
needs to be deleted much easier than
having to use voice commands to navigate
so I think it's the right answer is a
combination of both and uh and that's
the beauty of having both available one
little Wrinkle in our particular
implementation because we're using
web-based yeah web-based and web-based I
think it's
Mozilla XR I forget except webxr browser
forget which one it is
um we had issues getting
um the voice recognition on the hololens
2 to work
and so he works fine with their own apis
but the browser did not so we have to
use the mobile phone
for all the voice commands Okay so that
it's just a you know implementation
detail because of the current state of
the apis
thank you
excuse me hey
um so it was great to see an overview of
all the work
um my question is you know a lot of the
things that you showed
about using multiple displays or using
multiple devices or even about
collaboration
um
those are General things that I might
want for all sorts of computing
but you focused a lot on visualization
applications at least in what you showed
but I'm curious
how uh the use of these kinds of General
ideas
about using multiple displays or you
know devices
how they relate to visualization right
like what did you specifically learn
about visualization in these contexts
that is separate from what you would how
you would use these contacts for other
applications
yeah so it's you're absolutely right
that a lot of these things are generally
applicable
so uh
um yeah I mean I'm a database person of
course so that is my my default but uh
the uh there are some things that I
think that are specific to data one is a
lot of the work we're doing uses
situated data where
it has the data itself is in the world
it has a particular location like in the
relive system so so that case in that
case it makes sense to to actually focus
on data this
um
but I could easily see a lot of these
things having you know General usage and
and so on so
um it is I guess you know I I have some
blinders on because I'm a native person
but I certainly see that this is uh
relevant to a lot of other areas too
so a lot of your demos focused on the
use of like board scale interaction
right and of the sort of three
tripartite pitch of like tabs pads and
boards and Wiser's Visions I think the
boards are the one part that haven't
quite manifested in the in the same way
as maybe envisioned you know
typically when we see these kinds of
things today they're used for like a
single person control and just
projecting like I'm just sharing versus
if you sort of rewind to the Visions
they had like you know these Erp
collaborative sense making and you know
NASA movies where everyone's like
crowded around the gigantic wall size
display or like Sherlock who's just like
you know doing some mind Palace thing
that you know navigating some complex
data space
but it like in practice there's like
more manual actuation required I think
what I'm trying to drive at is where is
the threshold where you think this
actually flips and we use boards you
know in these sort of interactive touch
sensitive Etc ways rather than just as
the I'm gonna throw it on the wall and
you can look at it like what would it
take to get us over that threshold in
the visualization space where I would
use a board and preference to just the
laptop in front of me where I can you
know type and actuate it much faster
yeah I mean it it's a good point
for a couple of years ago tabletops were
big where everyone
were supposed to be gathering around a
tabletop and the benefit being that it's
big enough so you can you know multiple
people multiple people can gather around
it
um but yeah they're out of favor and I
think we're going we're just reaffirming
this quality Computing one device
to to rule them all so I don't know
I think we see that too in my lab that
we build a touch a big touch display
wall and it's not being used and it's
not it is it we don't get over that hump
where it is actually better
it it seems like those settings I think
they are
they're indicative of of how things like
collaboration in general happens most of
the time collaboration is not actually
in the same space same people those are
very small percentage so uh so I don't
know I mean I I guess I sound a little
pessimistic but I don't know if we'll
get to to that vision of boards uh and
big collaborative things because it it
feels like you have most of the benefits
on the actual pads and stuff
but it looks cool yeah it does yeah I
was just reflecting on that I was here
in this place where's the eye room and
so on all that work and and so it's it's
uh feels like uh
cool to be here
um thank you for the great talk um I
have a question about like where do you
see this kind of work going say in the
next five years a lot of the examples
that you showed are focused on like
analytics direct manipulation based on
visualization but like things are
changing in this anytime anywhere all at
once world with like question answering
and Legend analytics and like presenting
insights and interacting with insights
so there is this layer of abstraction
from the kind of work you showed today
so I'm curious to hear your thoughts on
like in this ubiquitous Computing world
like where do you see like the
visualization space going
yeah so definitely
um
it yeah it's definitely uh where is it
going I mean
uh a lot of the example that I show here
are are
various relatively simple data
visualizations but but
um we are seeing
with various forms of conversational
interfaces where you can ask questions
or you have interfaces where the the
insights there's some kind of
human-centered AI in the background that
is trying to to highlight or or Bubble
Up inferences or insights in there so I
think a future here is one that combines
these efforts
and um
so so it's also pretty closely tied to
to the some of the accessibility stuff a
lot of things we do for accessibility
are applicable for human analysts too
when you're moving in a in a physical
world you have limited attention you
have limited uh hands to to interact
with things than than having some
automatic algorithms to help you turn
out to be a essentially a curb cut
effect that we can bring in from
accessibility as well so yeah definitely
thank you
thank you very much for the talk
um I I was really interested in a couple
of the examples where there were these
like
spatial or like movement based
interactions so when you were showing
people like swiping from the screen onto
their watch or when there was the
collaboration example and people are
like walking close to each other I'm
Divergent
um and I was wondering kind of like how
you decide on what movements map to
different things especially like some of
them seem very intuitive like the
swiping I I think people would kind of
guess that would be but maybe the
raising of their hands to merge yeah um
wouldn't be I was wondering so like how
how you decide on those and if that maps
on to kind of the explicit implicit
um decision making that you were talking
about in the collaboration project I
mean it's a very good point in general
gestures are always low on
discoverability and so so this whole
argument of talking about natural user
interaction is a little fraught I think
so so in the case of the proxamic lens
work where you raise your hands we were
exploring a bunch of different uh action
and actions and figuring out in that
case that paper is a whole
um exploration saying where's the
boundary between implicit and explicit
but the decisions we made on which
gestures to use
is relatively arbitrary so in some cases
it makes sense but some of the actions
you're doing are so abstract so there's
no like natural way humans would do that
anyway
so so yeah I mean discoverability and
gestures in general is a super tricky
area the the one way we try to address
it in the visualization work
was to use like American sign language
which is you know some attempt at
grounding the actions we were doing with
some some real phenomenon that people
may have knowledge of but if they don't
that doesn't help then and even if they
do it's still going to be arbitrary that
you have to you know sign the first
letter for creating a new view in order
to to create that view so yeah I don't
have an answer for for these things it
is definitely not natural I think that's
a that's a non-moniker bad moniker
uh so I have a question actually
um
um so in the the visualization project
you were helping people author these 3D
Scatter Plots and I'm wondering like
four abstract like generic data analysis
tasks I think those are
often worse than like multiple 2D views
like you showed in like the large
display
uh example so I'm wondering like
do you see like
why is it good to help people author
these if if they're perhaps sub-optimal
or just your opinion on using this yeah
so 3D visualization yeah my dissertation
was realizing 3D visualization sucks so
so you don't want to do and I'm under an
ardent
adversary to 3D visualization so it is
it's not a good idea and uh the what you
saw here we try to do disciplined and we
try to do it where the day the 3D stuff
is not is motivated for I mean if if
you're doing the first to realize when I
started doing immersive analytics and
putting 3D visualizations and augmented
reality is to realize that if you're
doing things in in augmented reality
your visualizations will exist in 3D
whether you like it or not
so then you just have to realize how do
you do that efficiently so that you you
you don't get into occlusion and
navigation and perspective for
shortening and all that kind of problems
so
um so you want to be disciplined you
want to make sure that the
visualizations face you and there's no
depth information that's problematic and
so on so
um
sometimes it makes a lot of sense if the
data is 3D like the traces then seeing
it 3D definitely makes sense but if
you're trying to show and maybe if it's
a 3D surface that also makes sense but
but if it's bar charts there's really no
reason for you to create them in in 3D
so so I I'm aware that our
grammar enables you to do this and it is
onto us to guide people in future work
to not make those mistakes
I'm interested though like because like
people are like I I see a lot of these
visualizations that are maps with like
the bar charts or spikes and like laid
on top of them and like now that it's
getting easier for people to make these
even if like visualization experts think
or know it's a bad idea like that people
won't just do it so like how do you
think we should approach that problem
yeah I mean
um maybe the authoring tools need to
provide guidance to avoid some some
things like that and um
it is easier to do sometimes if you do
them for effect they can be useful for
storytelling but if you're trying to
compare a bar chart far in the distance
to one nearby you're going to have a bad
time so uh yeah it it is it is a problem
and I'm one that I've been battling
since my PhD really
thanks for the great talk and it was
great seeing all of these sort of
additional interactions that sort of
having multiple uh types of platforms
can enable in conjunction with each
other sort of going back to the
conversation about insights I was
wondering uh if you have any I guess
insights sorry for being redundant or a
lack of a better word for like the
additional types of insights that could
be gathered through having these
multiple displays and being able to
interact with them in a more embodied
sense
um that are in addition to just say like
having a large dashboard with sort of a
lot of synchronized visualizations or
um yeah what sort of these yeah so this
is a very good point I mean
every time I review papers on this topic
I ask myself what's the purpose of doing
it in in VR or ar
and so you need a good answer to get
past me as a reviewer and I try to do
that I turn that on myself too so there
are reasons why you want to do this one
one of course is that when you have a
immersive space you have more
physical space to place stuff in and you
can have embodiments you know muscle
memory you can have spatial memory that
you can take advantage of just knowing I
put my bar chart by my right hips I I
know exactly where to look for it which
is useful information
and then
the other reason Beyond just placement
is the fact that often even you put
stuff in in immersive then you get the
use of both of your hands or at least
some controllers
so that you can start uh you know by
manually grabbing things or moving
things around and so on so so uh I think
that that is another reason
and then you have some some more uh you
know maybe more
so and so reasons like things like
presence being there and and uh being
able to to just use physical navigation
to zoom in and out look closer or or
compare things you know change your
viewpoints and so on
great yeah thank you
thanks
so you're pitching these visualizations
that scale from you know in theory like
postage stamp size out to like a large
wall
and it strikes to me that
you're the kind of Cleveland and McGill
results that prompted what kinds of
visualizations we do where are gonna
break down at different scales of human
perception like the kind of rules and
that we derive from our perception at a
scale that's this small are going to be
different than the ones that hit when we
are when we're really huge have you
observed how the where and when those
principles bend and break or do they
actually still hold up in all instances
I think your intuition is correct
and uh the the one thing we have noticed
there might be others might be that when
you you know you might have
um
Halo effects where a group of elements
influence how certain elements in that
group are affected but of course if you
get close enough there might be enough
white space so so that thing diminishes
so
in general I think you're right and um
it would be interesting to to understand
that I just haven't and and I and I
don't think anyone has either you know
most of the most of the graphical
perception experiments and similar or
Donalds like standard screens that are
relatively small and yeah it'd be
interesting to to figure out
okay
any other questions
then let's thank our speaker one more
time
[Applause]